e
e e
okay the time being
10:04 I'm going to open the uh Revenue
estimate uh work session here and what
you have before you or you should all
have it as an
LSR um that was put together
that basically has the revenue estimates
that we voted on last week and uh you'll
see that on uh page two and Page Three
um I uh verified that those numbers were
what we agreed to but certainly uh I
welcome all you guys to to check those
numbers as well um this we'll be voting
on this to um to approve this and then
this will go into this will be assigned
a house resolution number and um
actually uh why don't I let uh cret give
us an update on this so as represent J
was saying that similar to an LSR that
you might file you sign off on that LSR
and then it goes up to the clerk and
they clerk assigns a number to it once
this LSR goes up to the clerk he will
assign a house resolution number to it
and then um include it in the calendar
for the next meeting so you won't see it
tomorrow at your session but you'll see
it on March
6 and you'll um at that point I think
representative Jinan and others may
speak to the resolution and then um in
the past it's been tabled um once it's
been uh passed and spoken
to that's that's it anyone have any
questions about the process
or okay s yes represent elme
yeah sor
I have had questions from a couple of
people who probably should know better
but on when we put that on the
table it automatically goes onto the end
of the budget correct or is there any
law about this anywhere or it's just
tradition uh no there's no law for that
basically what our office does is takes
what this committee agrees to Revenue
estimates and then we amend um House
Bill one under usually the finance
chair's name uh to put the unrestricted
revenues to reflect what this committee
has voted
on so we we're depending on
tradition well yeah yes and I'm not
aware that that's going to change I mean
that would be our recommendation to the
finance chair I think rbson Wier would
agree with us because that's how he's
done it in the past yes exactly uh in
fact he made a comment to that effect
yesterday I believe in full Finance yeah
some some people I hadn't maybe that was
after a lunch and conversation I had
thank you and my understanding is that
if we see some major changes on the
upside or downside whatever the case may
be we can propose pulling it off the
table and introducing new estimates yeah
absolutely it's it The house's desire or
will um
uh representative YY would you like to
make a motion
yeah yeah wrong room so I got to get
everything
together uh I would move to that the
uh
committee accept the house resolution
what number is this going to be we don't
we don't have just referen the LSR
number which is
25159 all right 25
1159 uh as ought to pass do I have a
second rubs them elme seconds it any
discussion Mr chair yes represent
shamber thank you Mr chairman I just
would like somewhere in the minutes to
to
reflect
that I still believe the business taxes
estimates are too high and should be
only about in the $900 million range
that is my estimation but I do support
the LSR to move forward thank you
anybody
else seeing none the I'll ask the clerk
to call the
role thank you Mr
chairman we are voting on LSR
25-11
059.0 codifying the revenue estimates of
the
committee the motion is ought to
pass seconded by President
Aly and
representative olry
um ought to pass yay yay representative
ducet yes clerks vote Yes representative
soti yes representative ORS yes
representative Smith yes Sten Smith
representative TIY yes representative
Brier yes representative Ford yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Aly yes representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
shamberg yes representative Bolton yes
representative elberger yes
representative Jeffrey
Smith he's not here
abson represent resentative Opel I
representative Spar yes chairman
janigian yes clerk
counts 19 to zero with one absent I'm go
close that door okay thank
you all right the vote is 19 to zero it
passes I'll uh close this uh session on
Revenue
is it
10 uh the time not being 10:15 yet uh I
cannot start the EXA uh but actually
what we're going to do is uh we're
starting the exec session around 10:15
but um uh Chris you have a handout for
us detail well I'll let Chris to explain
it but a a details information from the
governor's office the estimates we just
did and
um once everyone has that he can explain
in a little more
detail
oh
okay pull the
plug probably
we'll leave it to
S so if I might
just yes uh everyone has a handout now
uh Chris you wanted to so it's a it's a
two-page double-sided document the first
page is a shows you the general fund
education trust fund combined it's a
comparison what the governor's estimates
are to the house and ways estimates and
then the last three columns would be the
difference so it's house estimate minus
the governor's
estimate the second column in would be
the plan number for fiscal year
25 and you'll notice that about 2third
of the way down you'll see see and bold
on the left side changes to current law
so everything above that would be
current law to current law or Apples to
Apples
comparison below that is the new Revenue
that the governor is proposing um that
we're aware of in House Bill 2 which is
the vid video Lottery terminals in there
you'll see the governor's proposing um
they'll earn or collect $10 million in
Revenue in fiscal year 26 and $117
million in
27 this isn't included um in the house
estimates because the house has not
weighed in on this issue and has not
voted on it so if the house were to vote
and agree with the governor our office
would carry the revenue projections on
the Surplus statement it wouldn't change
your base
estimates and then the next two pages is
just a breakout of the general fund and
the education trust
fund similar to the split paper that I
worksheet I provided you last week again
following the same format with the
governor's estimates the house ways and
mean estimates and the difference um
house minus Governors again you'll see
that
um it's current law compared to current
law and then at the lower half of the
table you'll see changes to current law
the VT revenue is being split 50% to the
general fund 50% to the education trust
fund so you'll see that reflected on the
first line after the changes to current
law heading and then the next three
lines the business tax splits tobacco
splits and R splits the governor is
proposing to change the splits between
the general fund and the education trust
fund for those three uh revenue streams
to be 66% to the general fund 34% to the
education trust fund so as you move
over you can see the adjustments that
would happen um for instance the
business tax would have 84 and $87
million respectively going to the
general fund instead of the education
trust fund in 2016 and 27 and then you
would see a negative corresponding entry
on the education trust fund sheet um and
so that's similar work for the tobacco
split and the r split the red is a
little bit different in the sense that
um typically we did a 67% to 30 uh 3%
split and that's why you see a negative
on the general fund and then a positive
on the education trust fund again it's
below the current uh below the current
law estimates so again if the house
doesn't do this it goes
away and then the last page is just your
um Highway fund and your uh fishing game
fund repres elme yeah could I ask I
think you said that currently we're
splitting education trust fund and
general fund 5050 I thought it was
totally different uh 5050 for the video
Lottery the new Revenue source is 50/50
currently the business tax split for the
general fund education trust fund is um
59 41% so 59% of the business taxes go
to the general fund and um 41% go to the
education trust
fund and and that's all I have unless
there's any questions but I just wanted
to make sure the committee had this
since you'll be hearing about this uh
probably the next few days
representative
opal Chris what what's currently the
tobacco split is that also 5941 uh
tobacco is not uh an easy percentage to
do so right now we have to back out
about 17% of it which is the OTP other
than tobacco products because that all
goes to the general fund and then the
balance is split
um
uh 60 it's not 6 40 but it's close to
6040 and then we add back the piece that
we put the uh the other than tobacco
products back into the general fund so
it's a little bit more complex of a a
calculation um this would make it more
clear as to how you're splitting those
funds followup but but it would reduce
the education trust fund amount by was
four and a half million each year the
Bing yep thank you
yes represent ORS thank you Mr chairman
thanks for taking my question Chris
could you just give us those percentages
again I guess I'm I'm not clicking yet
on what what's happened here so for the
business tax currently VT business tax
tobacco right so the VT The Proposal is
that 50% of that Revenue go to the
general fund yep 50% go to the education
trust fund okay and the others for the
business taxes 59% goes to the general
fund currently 41% to the education
trust fund tobacco tobacco is not an
even
percentage okay that's where I was just
discussing where we have to back out and
then add something back in y for reddits
we do 6733 67%
33% okay very good thank
you we all
set repres el me your light is on but
now it's off okay very good thank you
Chris this is very helpful appreciate it
okay now we will start our executive
session um I'll open the executive
session on HB
669 and recognize representative ulery
for a motion I'm move
I do I have a
second representative duet seconds
uh would you like to speak to your
motion representative
YY not really
but this number one we have a a separate
committee that is dealing specifically
with education funding um this bill as I
read it and as the committee read it
or at least most of the committee read
it would do nothing more than increase
taxes and uh not necessarily
appropriate the uh fundes in the manner
in which would best Su serve our our
constituents and therefore I'm moving
itl any other
discussion yes represent
elme yes I do I was struck by by the
fact that uh Dan Maguire who is on the
school
funding um
program and Doug Hall who I've respected
for as many years as I've known him
which is a long time um felt that it
would be worthwhile keeping this uh oh
shoot just
is Sor I should turn this off
apologies um felt that it was important
to keep this concept the pieces of the
concept alive
somewhere uh rather than just it Ling
them while the
committee did its work
I'm not entirely sure that it's
necessary to do that in order to
resurrect part of this concept but um I
would like to respectfully disagree and
ask to retain thank
you anybody
else seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
call the
role thank you Mr chair
chairman we are voting it the vote is
itl on House Bill 669 FN relative to the
requiring all revenue raised under the
Statewide education property tax to be
deposited into the education trust fund
and setting up an equalized Statewide
tax
rate representative
alry
I representative duet yes clerk votes
yes
representative soti yes representative
ores yes Representative Steven Smith yes
representative Tierney yes
representative Brier yes representative
Ford yes representative Murphy yes
representative Aly no representative
Southworth no representative Maloy yes
Representative shamberg no
representative Bolton no
Representative elberger no
representative Jeffrey
Smith absent AB representative Opel no
representative Spar no chairman janigian
yes I count 13
yes that's not correct it's probably 12
12 yes thank
you
and seven
no yeah and one that
voting okay the vote being 12 to7 the
ital motion passes
and will there be a minority
report represent Aly is there Minority
Report on
this um yes
okay okay I'll close the exec session on
HB
669 okay I'm not going to open the exec
session on HB
and uh ask uh representative duet for a
motion thank you Mr chairman I move itl
on HB 290 FN do I have a
second representative
ORS would you like to speak to your
motion yes thank you Mr chairman we
heard testimony uh reasons to and
against uh raising the tax tax we derive
a substantial amount of
Revenue um on the cigarette
tax although this has a component for
the electronic and vape products it's my
understanding there's a piece of
legislation in the other body that's
going to address uh some of the issues
that we heard in testimony relative to
uh uh pirated issues and and taxes being
collected
so uh seeing that you know this is part
of the New Hampshire Advantage keeping
taxes low and in bringing those revenues
in uh that's why I support the
itl thank you anybody
else uh I see everyone pointing to
somebody else representative Shamburg uh
um Southworth oh stayed
on now I'll put mine on all right
uh when we heard the discussion uh
representative Stringham who had made
the presentation had listened intently
to what was being said about vaping and
cigarette taxes coming in under the same
bill he had provided with to me two
amendments that maybe would
address the
amount of Revenue that might be able to
go into the general fund for this year
and that's the one that
would 20250
0468 H that would effective upon passage
and we're looking at a revenue deficit
and he uh was hoping that this committee
would at least take a look at that and
say okay let's we have not had an
increase since 2013
a178 we have not kept up with inflation
it would still be the lowest tax on
cigarettes in the surrounding states the
other amendment that he was proposing
was don't pass the immediate passage but
pass the second amendment that would
deal with if main passes theirs which
would be in the $3 range that the State
of New Hampshire would then have a bill
here that could address raising their
rate to
278 uh
which is going to put more Revenue into
the general fund
um I feel that that we should at least
try to address this uh it's not going to
affect Massachusetts at
$341 I think on uh uh cigarette tax
right now uh and even at 278 they're
still going to come across the border
and we're going to at least put more
Revenue in into our general
fund so just wanted to let you know that
that's out there that thought process
was out
there thank you representative Spire
thank you I thought it was 2009 but
maybe it was 2013 when the it was raised
a178 and I am concerned because of
inflation that you know the dollar 78
then is not certainly not worth that
today it's probably 60 C so yes it has
gone down but we do need to I think keep
it up with inflation because uh it's
eroding you know overall our budget and
I am concerned about the fact that I
understand that the governor is planning
on taking from the rainy day fund
because of the deficit this year and if
her deficit is her deficit and our
deficit is our deficit it's going to be
substantially more she's going to be
taking from the rainy day fund and uh I
think this helps to stem it by raising
this uh fee to at least keep with
inflation uh yes
represent thank you Mr chair uh just
want to say that I was not here in body
last week but I watched every second of
the meetings last week it was
fascinating to watch it not be able to
participate uh I would have preferred to
be here uh I would like to just comment
on representative duet's statement about
the New Hampshire Advantage with low
taxes and as I I uh mentioned before a
couple of weeks ago state taxes may be
lower but the property taxes that our
constituents are concerned
about have been brought to the attention
not only of the Democrats here but I'm
sure that some of you as Republicans are
also hearing the concerns about high
property taxes we are not providing a
New Hampshire advantage to our local
property taxes by continuing to cut or
not increase Revenue that comes in on
the state level so I uh will oppose this
ideal represent yeah just to respond
briefly we we've all heard that
messaging the problem with this
particular tax is
the clients the customer the customer
base is doing this and a lot a lot of
effort myself included I quit smoking so
we we have Revenue doing this right now
if we jack a tax on this at a dollar a
pack we're going to lose what Revenue we
have in the state I know I made a
promise when I ran for office that I
would not approve or support any new
taxes and I stand by
that the the local property tax rate is
dictated at the local level that should
be addressed at the local level
represent elme thank you I don't want to
get into a conversation about the uh
difficulty of towns and uh addressing
State problems but um I do want to
suggest that we consider on
representative stringham's second uh
idea which is
to to um pass something
now which could become automatic if
repres Aly we're talking about an itl
motion right now yes I know on you're
we're talking about iing it instead of
considering uh the effectiveness of
being able to add to that tax if
Maine
uh uh decides to become uh uh to
increase its taxes as it's been talking
about but not
otherwise
on inflation has taken away a huge part
of the effectiveness of this for
stopping people smoking which is one
side of the equation the other side of
the equation is that um we're losing
Revenue because of the inflation that's
been going on for quite some time now
and this is one place that uh it it uh
addresses two problems one of which is
our revenues and the other of which is
on the health of our of our citizens so
representative Spar um with respect to
representative ducet uh most of our tax
revenue comes from sources that are a
percentage and if uh your pledge is no
new taxes then those other ones should
not be a percentage should be a flat fee
so we're just trying to keep this up
with inflation at a minimum and I think
that makes a lot of sense because it's
basically continue to deescalate or at
least decline excuse me and uh I don't
think that's healthy from a revenue
perspective I mean to me representativ
duet's um point about how less and less
people are smoking it's interesting this
a higher tax could trigger um several
people many people to say you know what
I'm done now I'll quit that would be
part of my concern representative ulery
and that was my concern speaking to the
percentage when you um increase the
percentage on a declining population
then you're also decreasing the amount
of Revenue that is being
generated represent op U did you I would
just like and I don't think there's any
way to predict how many people will uh
stop smoking or see smoking and how much
that dollar an extra pack will offset
that it could be be actually more even
with a decrease of people so that's not
that's not easy to predict and I don't
think there's any way we can but uh I
would uh still think it's a a worthy
goal to at least keep it with where it
was at a178 back in 2009 which would be
substantially more than what it is
representative opal well like
representative du said I'm a former
smoker um and I'm assuming my colleague
um is glad that he made that decision um
as I I think most people should maybe
all people should um uh two points
though one specific to the revenue
argument which is that we have an
estimate uh on the fiscal note saying
that this will generate uh 87 and a half
million dollars if I'm reading the table
correctly in in um in each year of the
bium I believe so at least through the
next two years next two fiscal years
there should be an increase um
concurrently with that though um and I
know it's not necessarily A purview of
this committee it's more appropriate in
finance but any decline in
smoking um is going to have uh a a
similar decline in the cost of health
care for those for those
individuals um and you know I think I
think that's just you know that's going
to that's going to have an impact on the
state's budget as well well on on the on
the expenditure side thank you Mr okay
one more one more representative do yeah
I I don't want to belabor it and I
appreciate it but as as an
ex-smoker um to me adding a dollar per
pack would kill the market kill our
advantage and kill the revenue we
see simple economics if I smoke and
choose to continue to
smoke is it worth me spending $8 in gas
to come up to New Hampshire to buy my
cotton of cigarettes I'll stay in
Massachusetts or I'll stay in Vermont or
main or whatever
so thank
you okay um I'm GNA ask the clerk to
call the role thank you Mr chairman the
motion on the floor is
itl on House Bill 29 FN and act
increasing the taxes on cigarettes and
electronic cigarettes and establishing a
committee to study taxes on Tobacco and
other nicotine products representative
Al I representative duet yes clerk votes
yes representative sodi yes
representative ores yes representative
Stevens Smith yes representative Tierney
yes representative Brier yes
representative Ford yes representative
Murphy yes representative Aly no
representative Southworth no
representative Malloy no Representative
shamberg no representative Bolton no
Representative elberger no
representative Jeffrey
Smith out representative Opel no
representative Spar no chairman Jian
yes by a vote of 11
to9 eight
11 to8 one
abent okay the vote being 11 to8 the itl
motion passes and I'm closing the exec
session works there will be a Minority
Report okay I think we need to discuss
should uh motion U
microphone uh there will be a Minority
Report um probably ought to pass this
amended and
um we need to discuss it later okay let
me
know okay next I'm going to open the
exec session on
hb42 and recognize representative Murphy
thank you Mr
chairman
um I'm moving to uh
inexpedient uh litigate or legislate
this uh particular HB 402 because only
each family can make a determination of
whether or not the EFA is taxable to
them or not based on their individual
tax situation not the state of New
Hampshire through broad legislation such
as this the issue hasn't been a problem
I'm sorry uh R Murphy I didn't get a
second um do I have a second on this
representative sod second it you may
sorry um so only an individual family
can determine whether or not an EFA is
taxable to them or not based on their
individual tax situation not the state
through broad legislation of this and
that's usually in consultation with a
tax professional this issue hasn't been
a problem yet because efas currently
restrict the program to low-income
families who typically um you know file
very basic tax returns where they're not
itemizing or in some cases don't pay any
taxes at all I'm concerned that the bill
as it currently is written might result
in unintended consequences and so I feel
it's in expedient to legislate thank you
than
you represent
elme thank you uh I sent you but I
didn't get anything back on a proposal
to amend this and to amend it in a way
that would
inform uh the people that have
EFA that they are immune from New
Hampshire taxes but uh may be subject to
Federal taxation I think that that cures
the whole
bill uh it it would replace the the
sentence that we all agree is is
misleading but it would um would allow
the the
um the state to avoid any liability from
telling people that they are immune from
all taxes
uh which is what we do now uh and it
would be an extremely simple fix so I
would just like to put that out into the
conversation since we haven't had a
conversation together yet so thank you
any
other comments representative Southworth
um just briefly I did have a chance and
I sent it to some um to get the handbook
for the efas and if you haven't seen it
it's really interesting it's very
detailed very well organized handbook
but it has a clear list especially for
homeschoolers what they can and cannot
use their wallet money for and that list
does not match up with a list of what is
taxable so it's pretty easy if you put
up the two lists to see that there are
things on their list that you can
definitely get with your EFA homeschool
money that are definitely taxable so I
do think um looking to the Future it
would be possible or preferable to look
into this a little bit longer and one
thing that's been reported you cannot
use efas um for theme parks because I've
seen that in the news and heard it it is
not true thank you okay thank you
represent
elberger thank you Mr chair I just would
like to uh point out that uh
representative Murphy's statement about
all of the recipients of efas are low
income given the current cap of 135,000
or so dollars per year for a family of
four I have not heard that ever referred
to as a family with low income thank
you okay seeing
no one else with a comment I'll ask the
clerk to call the rooll on HB
402 thank you Mr chairman the vote is I
the motion is itl on House Bill 402 an
act relative to liability as taxable
income on education Freedom account
payments representative alry I
representative ducet yes clerk votes yes
representative sodi yes representative
ORS yes Representative Steven Smith yes
representative Tierney yes
representative Bri
yes representative Ford yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Aly no representative Southworth no
representative Malloy no Representative
shamberg no representative Bolton no
Representative elberger no
representative Smith is absent
representative Opel no representative
Spar no chairman janigan yes
Thank
You by vot of 11
to8 Direction
11 the vote being 11 to8 uh the it
motion passes and I'm going to close the
exec session on HP
402 uh Rose elme is there yes there will
be a Minority Report on I'll probably
write it but we can discuss it
afterwards okay let me know will be
ought to pass as amended with the
language that I just
provided okay I'm going to open the
executive session on HB
483 and recognize representative Tierney
for a
motion itl for this bill do I have a
second representative so seconds it
would you like to speak to your motion
representative
tney this is a very short
Bill uh the main uh part of this one is
that the scholarship organization that
handles uh the EFA accounts uh is to be
incorporated in this state it is not
Incorporated in this state it's
Incorporated in the state of New York
and by saying it has to be done here I
believe it would be in violation of the
US Constitution
Commerce Clause and that's why I made
the
motion representative
Aly thank you I uh passed out to
everybody something that is rather
difficult to read it is from the 10 the
uh 990 for the new New York State on on
what do they call it
um on
family children's Children's scholarship
fund that's it on the only piece of it
that I could find at any rate that has
anything to do with uh our program is
4B and 4B says that they are
administering here program management
and administration of new hampsh
Hampshire education Freedom account
program uh the program provides students
who are not enrolled full-time in a New
Hampshire public school and whose family
earns 350% of the poverty L line or
below with a state Grant to spend on
eligible education related expenses
cfsf the New York group administers the
funding provided from the state of New
Hampshire to each account program staff
verifies elig ability through the
application process reviews and approves
payment of eligible expenses and
approves educational providers in
addition program staff provide Outreach
and support to New Hampshire families to
inform them about the EFA program and
and then it says that during fiscal year
24 CSF received 23.5 million from the
state of New Hampshire to fund over 4900
efas
um that sounds like a
contract rather than that we
are
are it sounds like the EFA
program isn't part of an incorporation
anywhere and I would like us
to look a little further into this
instead of saying that
it's that the legal situation is
correct so I would like I would not want
to kill this bill I would like to retain
it represent
opal
um based on what I was reading about the
um the governor's budget presid
presentation I thought this piece of
legislation was in keeping with her
um desire to try and uh Target outof
State
contractors um and so it seemed like
this might be in keeping with that
initiative
but anybody
else seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
call the roll thank you Mr chairman the
motion is itl on House Bill 483 FN
relative to the definition of a
scholarship Organization for purposes of
the education tax
credit representative
olry yes representative ducet yes clerk
votes yes representative so yes
representative ores yes representative
Stevens Smith yes representative TIY yes
representative Brier yes representative
Ford yes representative Murphy yes
representative Aly no representative
Southworth no representative Maloy no
Representative shamberg no
representative Bolton no Representative
elberger no representative Smith is
absent Jeffrey Smith representative Opel
no representative Spar no Mr chairman by
a vote of 11 you haven't called on me
yet I know you're trying to avoid
the pronunciation almost got through
represent Janan
yes thank you Mr chairman by a vote of
11 to8 one
absent
I the vote being 11 to8 the itail motion
passes and I'm going to close the exact
session on HP 483 will there be a
Minority
Report microphone please there will be a
Minority Report we'll figure out who's
going to do it thank you okay
representative buy yeah what would the
motion the motion would be retained
motion would be retain I'm not sure if
we're allowed to say retain in which
case we would have to say ought to pass
with Amendment or something like that
okay we'll look into that unless
representative Smith knows the answer
yeah retain is a committee function not
a committee report so that's not not
appropriate okay thank you that makes
sense all right all right I'm going to
open the executive session on HB
503 and recognize representative ORS for
motion thank you Mr chairman I make the
motion to itl this legislation HB 503 F
thank you do I have a
second representative do set seconds
it would you like to speak to your
motion representative ORS yes Mr
chairman I would
so this legislation amends how tax
revenues are allocated to both the
general trust fund and the education
trust fund and it increases many
taxes uh and tax rates business profits
tax business Enterprise tax meals and
rooms and reestablishes the indd
tax what's amazing to me also is that
the other party ran on a position of no
new taxes I would quote Joyce Craig many
times but in the interest of time I will
not however it's obvious uh that
somebody didn't get the message because
all we have here are many tax
increases versus what was actually
pledged uh all these new
taxes uh the intent is on some of these
of course is also to reduce the funds
the revenues to the general fund which
again is surprising to me when I've
heard a lot of angst about there's not
going to be enough money for the general
fund which I personally believe we are
going to be just fine so therefore I am
uh again I am recommending itl on this
legislation thank you and I think
representative schenberg has something
to say could you tell that by the way I
was pushing the button before he
finished you were you were very anxious
there thank you Mr chairman uh
House Bill
503 uh would redirect over $700 million
back to the state coffers by
2027 as uh stated by the state director
of national Federation of Independent
Business uh and it comes back to the uh
State because of the tax cuts that have
been going on since
2015 it's a bill designed
to go raise the present tax
rates back to their original number like
the BPT from 7.5 it's at now to
8.5 the 0.5 on B to
75 uh the meals and rooms from 8.5 to 9
and the newly named recommendation at
the Dr told me to change the interest
and dividend to something else so I
Chang it to Market distribution Revenue
all 5% of that uh the additional
percentage that would be added on would
strictly go back into the education
trust fund
and I feel that it would help address
some of the issues that we've had about
funding and property tax
relief um our present public policy on
funding public education and property
tax relief I
think
exacerbates what is going on by doing
this I think we
mitigate a crisis
so I feel
that this is something that would help
address uh our budget
and my colleague down here to the right
uh
it does not reduce the general fund of
presently what is going to come into
it the all the percentage increases put
the money into the education trust
fund thank you Mr
chairman I just I just would I I can't
um I know how my constituents would
react to all these tax increases how do
you feel like your constituents would
react to knowing that there's so many
tax tax increases on the table when
people are struggling right
now people are uh these taxes other than
the meals and rooms these taxes are not
affecting the everyday
homeowner
or or property owner these would help
adjust bring their property taxes down I
don't have many constituents that
own uh uh uh the the big businesses that
are missing out paying on this paying
into supporting the market supporting
our
infrastructure
uh I I do not believe that the folks of
wilmet and
Sutton would say you're raising it on a
multinational business by a percent it's
going to go into the education trust
fund which then is going to be able to
use for funding for public education and
reduce my property taxes I I don't see
that coming across from my
constituents well the thing that would
concern me I have a lot of in Salem and
I'm sure in Wilmont too there's a lot of
small businesses who have llc's who
would be subject to these taxes as
well uh representative ORS thank you
again Mr chairman having anticipated my
esteemed colleagues remarks I saved the
best for last
and that we have seen repeatedly over
the years as we have cut the BPT tax the
BET tax etc etc that our revenues have
gone up so much for so that in the case
of educational trust fund those monies
going in increase from 25% of that fund
to 39% which we have seen in the
presentations that were provided to us
earlier in the year and therefore I
totally disagree that we would increase
the general fund with new taxes this
money is not going to flow in this money
is going to be walking away again as
we've cut the tax we've increased the
revenue and just like the tobacco taxes
and so on that are uh so ra outrageously
high as presented I mean this whole idea
is going up in smoke thank
you representative shamur hopefully I've
got the best one at the end here to
thank you Mr chairman I'm not done
yet uh there is no proven theory that
when you cut the tax rate that revenues
increase that has been demonstrated by
the uh budget uh that comes out of
Washington
DC uh it seems when you cut
Revenue deficits
increase when you have a proper tax
system set up
up revenues come in and you have to you
you will have less deficit because you
don't have to borrow as much
money represent
Aly thank you and I believe on that the
representative has
uh has many good and important things to
say in this
bill but
uh these taxes have been around for a
long time and
they should not be going
back in the same way that they were
there before uh if uh the legislature
lived up to the fact that we need the
same amount of Revenue
adjusted for inflation that we had back
10 years ago when the taxes started to
be
cut um there this is a long-term project
it's not something that uh obviously
that could happen
today and the idea that it would all go
to the education trust fund when the
general fund does enormous work needed
to keep the this state together and to
keep families together and to keep
people
healthy um is
um is difficult so I will be voting no
on
this and uh see how everyone else goes
thank you thank you represent ORS thank
you again Mr chairman so once again my
esteemed colleague to my left
uh mentioned how when we cut taxes in
Washington DC the uh things don't go the
way they seem they should go well
there's a good reason for that a two
things one we're not talking about
Washington DC we're talking about facts
provided by the state of New Hampshire
for New Hampshire and as the tax
revenues the tax rates have
increased have been cut the revenues
increase the other thing I like to say
is the reason we don't see cost
expenditures going down in Washington DC
is because of all the waste Fraud and
Abuse that dogee has uncovered like
millions of dollars going for condoms
and stuff like that for the terrorists
so it's a pretty easy understand thank
you represent El me thank you we have a
very strong narrative now on
that has been backed up with facts that
shows that when we increased the revenu
when we decreased the revenues was after
when we got the stimulus money that is
various different kinds of stimulus
money the first one was tax cuts and
jobs
act the time before that was just New
Hampshire caping catching up with every
other state because it takes is longer
than it takes any other state to uh to
get get to where our revenues are where
they were before the Great
Recession
uh that was the burst we had in
16 uh I'm not going to go on further
about that but in each case on we cut
the taxes just about the same time that
the revenue was being formed already
that went into our taxes the year or two
after that's the way our tax system
works uh
so what would happen if we did a bad tax
reform what would happen if we did a
good tax reform is something that we may
discover someday but we will find we
will uh it has nothing to do with
whether uh
whether the idea itself is important for
the State of New Hampshire or not thank
you um I just want to take one more
because I think we can see where this is
headed uh representative elberger had
her hand up
first thank you Mr chair and I I I'm not
sure that the conversation has really
changed anyone's mind to be fair uh I
will point out um three things one is
that to the best of my knowledge
property taxes have gone up somewhere in
the 35 to 38% rate in the Statewide over
the last few
years whatever property decreases have
happened on the state level property
taxes have gone up the response of well
that's the
local uh decision making and people
should just want Less in their
communities um well education
firefighters police officers getting our
roads plowed in the
winter this year particularly all of
those things come out of local property
taxes the addition
of the costs being downshifted has been
really damaging so that's number one
number two and I I may have mentioned
this before um my husband and I like
going out to diners and we particularly
enjoy su's in uh Hudson uh which is in
representative 's district I was talking
to a waitress there and asking her
if the uh meals tax were to drop how she
would feel about that she said she'd
like that because sometimes she goes out
to eat I said if you had to choose
between the meal tax going down and your
property taxes going down which would
you prefer no question in her mind she
would rather have her property taxes
down and lastly one of the things that
I've learned is that saying that we are
going to continue to do things just
because this is the way we've always
done them is a really bad basis for
decision making thank you Mr
chair I'm gonna ask the clerk to call
the
role thank you Mr chairman the motion is
itl on House Bill 50 3 FN an act
amending how revenues from taxes are
allocated to the education trust
fund representative
alry yes representative ducet yes the
clerk votes yes representative soti yes
representative ores yes representative
Stevens Smith yes representative Tierney
yes representative Brier yes
representative Ford yes representative
Murphy yes representative
Aly yes representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes Representative
shamberg no representative Bolton yes
Representative elberger no
representative Jeffrey Smith is absent
representative Opel no representative
Spar
yes represent the
Jian
yes
almost uh represent um clerk counts 16
Ys and three
Nays okay the vote being 16 to three the
itl motion passes and I'll close the
exec session on HB
503 uh did you have a comment
representative shamberg there will be a
Minority Report and it will be you yes
it will be so we have one Minority
Report
determined what will the report
be uh
okay I'm now going to open the exec
session on HB
531 and recognize representative duet
thank you Mr chairman I move itl on HB
531 FN do I have a
second second second by represent Aly
and would you like to speak to your
motion represent yes thank you Mr
chairman for the sake of brevity I think
this is uh one of the many issues that
the newly formed hopefully gaming
commission can
address in that nest of issues they need
to
address sounds good any other
comments
thoughts seeing
none you agree okay thank you seeing no
more I'll ask the clerk to call the role
thank you Mr chairman the motion is itl
on House Bill 531 FN setting the annual
limits on the amount of chable Gaming
revenue which may be distributed to un
chable organization
representative Olie yes representative
ducet yes clerk votes yes representative
sodi yes representative ORS yes
Representative Steven Smith yes
representative Tierney yes
representative Brier yes representative
Ford yes representative Murphy yes
representative Aly yes representative
Southworth yes representative Malloy yes
representative shamberg yes
representative Bolton yes representative
Elbert
yes representative Jeffrey Smith is
absent represent Opel I representative
Spar yes representative janigian
yes 19
to1 19 to zero one absent right okay the
vote being 19 to zero the itl motion
passes and is there any objection to oh
it's an
FFN so I don't believe this can go on
consent okay I'm going to close the exec
session on HB
next I'm going to go slightly out of
order here I'm going to open the exec
session on HB
588 and look to representative ducet for
a motion thank you Mr chairman move itl
on HB 588 FN do I have a
second second well no well second
representative El me second
it she was I saw the hand reaching
reaching for the
light uh would you like to would you
like to speak to your motion
representative duet um Yes again briefly
I think this
is an issue that can be brought up at
the uh Gaming Commission
along with a plethora of
others true enough anybody anybody
else okay good seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role on HB
588 thank you Mr chairman the motion is
itl on HB 588 FN an act relative to the
distribution of revenues generated from
historic horse racing paramutual
pools representative iy yes
representative ducet yes
repres the clerk votes yes
representative soti yes representative
ORS yes representative Stevens Smith yes
representative Tierney yes
representative Brier yes representative
Ford yes representative Murphy yes
representative Aly yes representative
Southworth yes representative Malloy yes
representative shamberg yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative Jeffrey
Smith is not present representative Opel
I representative Spar yes representative
janigian
yes counts 190 with one
absent okay the vote being 19 to zero
the itl motion passes and this will not
go on consent either because it is uh
has a financial impact close the exact
session on HP
588 Mr chair yes did you say you can't
put it on consent yes is that not true
uh my understanding is whenever there's
a 588 588
FN you can't pass bills with fiscal um
allocations and put them on consent
didn't we just itl this
one oh I see if it's itl it can go on
cons right so there's no allocation
coming out from the many you are
permitted to put it on consent if you
wish then in that case um HB 588 and HB
531 uh can go on
consent uh no no no no no those unless
you all want to change your
votes
okay got one more we got
483 yeah no 54
540 did we have a vote on this one we
haven't
done we
did just 540 you were taking them out of
order 4 483 is already done that's 11
was 11
to8 break
483 where is
that oh
yeah all right I'm
gonna I'm gonna open the exact session
on HB
540 and recognize representative duet
thank you Mr chairman I move itl and HB
540 do I have a second
representative uh Murphy second
it would you like to speak to your
motion again if if the commission
chooses to do so this is an issue that
can be brought
up with uh with that commission
um personally I I think it it singles
out a a specific
entity for an exorbitant
tax which can you know it talks about a
th000 machines you know they can put in
999 machines this this is something that
although I may or may not agree
with the spirit of this I think it's
something that should be addressed at
the upcoming
commission thank you
other thoughts comments
representative ORS did you why your
light is on I don't know if that's by
accident representa
elberger I uh thank you Mr chair I find
myself in agreement with representative
ducet here and hoping that uh when the
commission takes a look at it they can
look at graduated levels of machines you
know this range and this range and this
range thank you thank you represent
Aly thank you um that's about where I am
and this
is rather more money I think for uh
than than we should be asking for from a
large casino but uh we do have large
casinos now instead of one large casino
that we were fighting about and
everybody objected to first uh and um
they are getting away with a lot more
money
than than um
is is
available uh on the southern side of our
border for
instance uh so um we're I'm I'm voting
itl also but but I just wanted to say
that representative opal Mr chairman I I
just have a question honestly um
representative duet I think correctly
has ident identified a myriad of
questions that hopefully the uh the
newly formed when it gets approved will
address but I'm wondering if the house
or this legislature has the ability to
provide any guidance to that Commission
in terms of questions that we would like
to see
addressed well go ahead repr thank you
Mr chairman I I would suggest that the
only voting members are memb of the
house in the Senate and anybody and
everybody can come testify bring their
information in front of that commission
which we had a lot of
interaction finding some of these very
issues in the last commission yeah
representative duet and I were both on
that on the last B enums commission and
uh there's a lot of issues that need to
be addressed um and people can come and
testify at those at those
times anybody else
representative are you ready to vote is
that what you okay well
speak did you have a comment on this
okay all right I'm seeing none I'll ask
the uh substitute clerk to call the role
who is actually the clerk at this
moment that means I can push the button
right
can the bill oh yes I have uh the bill
is uh hb5 uh 40 relative to uh historic
horse racing and large facilities motion
is to uh inexpedient to
legislate
and I vote
Yes isn't that fun
oh representative duet yes
representative om is absent
representative sodi yes repres
representative SS yes or excuse me thank
you Representative Steven Smith yes
representative turny yes KY excuse me
representative Brier
yes representative Ford yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Aly yes
representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes Representative
shamberg
no representative Bolton
yes representative elberger yes she's
right Susie is a good place rep uh
representative Jeffrey Smith is absent
representative opal
I and representative Spar yes and
chairman janigian yes oh
wow missed missed St oh yeah
thank 17 to 1 to
two two two
absent the vote being 17 to1 um is itl
passes is there any um objection to
consent seeing none we'll put this on
consent and I'll close the exact session
for HP
540 okay that finishes our business for
today um there's a scheduled meeting for
Friday obviously I'll announce now that
that will be cancelled there's no need
to come back on Friday um I know many of
you are
disappointed um and uh extra 50 bucks
next week uh next week um there's no
house session as you all should know and
I also am not scheduling any uh meetings
next week as well so uh the next meeting
will probably Monday um whatever the
first Monday in March Monday and Tuesday
potentially in March uh will be and
that'll be out and um not this current
calendar probably the next
calendar question not
Wednesday no I don't think we need to
meet we're after today we basically uh
if my count is uh correct we only have
eight bills left after this so with
eight bills left all our early bills are
done um and we have till March 20th to
get the last eight bills out our Revenue
estimates are done uh so we're in good
shape um so two two meetings the first
can March at the most at this point uh
yes represent opal is it is it the
chair's intent to maintain just for
planning purposes will we will we be
planning on Monday Tuesday the rest of
the month through the through the 20
it's the 20th probably now we may not
need every Monday and Tuesday um and if
we only need one day um I may try to
default to
Tuesdays uh because I know a lot of
people try to make a point s2i on
Mondays and Fridays um
so yes it'll be it'll be Monday Andor
Tuesday but probably Tuesday if only one
day but but first week of March Monday
and Tuesday um unfortunately I don't
know right now I'll probably know in the
next uh three or four
days okay anybody
else seeing none thank you
everyone oh I'm sorry wait a minute do
you want your not sure where to put it
uh I've got an announcement for the
Democrats we're going to have to have a
conclave now and I just tried to ask for
a room I don't know what we'll get so
maybe we can just uh stay
here that's fine okay okay thank you
everyone uh it's kind
of I rush I can
get
e
e e